warum macht ihr überhaupt noch an den
antwort ich weiß es nicht
die botschaft sie ist wichtig weißt du
das schweizer pendant angst ja das ist
längst nicht wieso dabei verschweigt
denkt gfk ich weiß arosa voll mit berge
ja als geldmaschine verstehst du pauli
comedian sind einzig und allein oft
bühne und lustig sie das ist toll wenn
man sieht wie kein kompromiss muss
machen und wenn es funktioniert quasi
aus ganz europa berühmt aber wenn es
nicht funktioniert das wenn die bühne
ging und ich mache neue nummer eins
gerufen wie dem publikum natürlich artig
und sie negative energie über und dass
ich unglaublich hart findet sogar das
allein muss ertragen
im alleingang will michael elsener nach
zwölf erfolgreichen jahren in der
schweiz nun auch deutschland erobern
der 32 jährige zuger hat sich in den
kopf gesetzt die deutschen zum lachen zu
bringen
[Musik]
ich begleite den studierten politologen
auf seiner lach mission nach berlin und
will herausfinden warum ihnen die
schweiz zu klein geworden ist und er
wieder ganz unten anfängt wie hart es
für schweizer spaß mache in deutschland
ist zeigt die tatsache dass in den
letzten 100 jahren eigentlich nur zwei
durchschlagenden erfolg hatten gefühlte
das riesige scala theater in berlin der
1920 er jahre und seit 1970 er jahren
ist in steinberger auch in deutschland
kult
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in der schweiz bin ich extra konto der
mit der parodie seit märz fiel türe
geöffnet und schon gefunden
aber in deutschland ist ein tolles
erfolgreich das programm zu machen ohne
die polo die eigentlich ins programm
[Musik]
mit der eroberung des deutschen
publikums setzt sich der prix walo
preisträger ein hohes ziel im comedy
club kookaburra so sein weg nach oben
beginnen
hallo danke schön soll ich mitkommen
gleich nachgehen wenn die garderobe dann
erst mal kannst du dich gemütlich machen
sanchez ivorer ist selbst komiker im
club ist er für die planung zuständig
elsener hat er erstmals für ein
gastspiel gebucht und also hier mal
hallo dann rede ich über die schweizer
emotionen wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr da
das headset auch zu machen
24 wurden nachrichten als wichtige in 30
sekunden
ich mache das aus ich da überhaupt an
deinen gott meint sie es dann ja ich
habe sonst auch noch eine box also aber
lasst uns mal kurz überlegen also hier
das funktioniert ja weil ich auch wenn
es funktioniert macht halten
na ja also ich muss man also mit der
rettung vom mond fliegen also wir werden
die fünfte xlr leitung funktioniert
ein korken sie den bürger vor sich in
der ruhe
doch kurz bevor er zu schnappt sie der
noch die angelschnur und denkt sich
[Musik]
von mir das muster tragen geben
unhaltbar seit 2002 42 den comedy club
gemeinsam mit seiner frau svenja und
[Gelächter]
stockte der dribbelkünstler die länge im
kabarett auftreten bietet sanjai gleich
um die ecke als unterkunft eine kleine
wohnung ausgebaut gesamte möbel selbst
gebaut
das habe ich auch gemacht hier ja ich
hab's nicht so krass geschliffen ich
habe es noch ein bisschen so ja
noch vor der ersten vorstellung muss
michael zu einem radiointerview
ich weiß nicht ich muss mir auch ganz
aktuelle interviews und jedoch deutlich
zeigen
aber ich habe mich sowohl bürgel 2010
hat elsener sein hobby zum beruf gemacht
seit seinem master an der universität
zürich setzt der voll auf die karte
komik
[Musik]
naja
mit hilfe einer pr agentin hat mich als
managerin für deutschland das geschafft
ihn in einer radioshow beim rundfunk
berlin-brandenburg zu schleusen
[Musik]
moderatorin raphaela jungbauer erklärt
michael den ablauf die dach lounge geht
live zur besten sendezeit um 19 uhr auf
sendung
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der puls ist sie wie diesen dank der
ausschuss und 80 chf stecken wir sie mit
dem auto und vor allem risiko das
programm noch mal umgestellt und mit den
anderen um und dann auch sei geplant
haben von dem ich zurücktreten ich
glaube jetzt einfach mode
ich bin nicht alleine ich komme aus der
schweiz und hab ich etwas falsches
gesagt es ist schön du schon auch ihre
emotionen da auf den gesichtern zu sehen
das ist extrem toll dass es ist für mich
auch zweifel wie es schon ungewohnt wenn
ein schweizer etwas wahnsinnig genial
und spitze findet dann sagte so gibt es
immer wieder deutsche oder die kommen zu
mir und sagen so ach weißt du michael
die deutschen wir sind so verhalten
sagen können eigenschaften der liebe ja
meine güte liebe deutsche im vergleich
zu uns ist alles brasilien michael
elsener den wahrscheinlich lustigsten
speicher aller zeiten und von der ganzen
welt hallo ich habe mich vorher gefragt
ob du mich überhaupt verstehst wenn ich
so rede unterlag das also ein bisschen
vor augen geguckt wurden und da war ich
dort die tiefen gedachten wir vielleicht
verstehst du mich gar nicht dass du bist
die intelligenteste radiomoderator in
ganz deutschland und der ganzen welt und
ich würde sogar noch an händen des
ganzen universums
all das was reizt dich an deutschland
in der schweiz ist es mir eigentlich
kommt die mäßig ziemlich gut gelaufen
also ich musste diese ochsentour eben
wenig machen
das hat gleich funktioniert und dann
hatte ich glaube ich irgendwie unbewusst
glaube ich einfach auch lust mal wieder
so unten anzufangen klinken zu putzen
ganz unten heute ganz oben also
irgendwie ich darf das ja in der schweiz
nicht sagen aber er denkt schneller als
wir
[Gelächter]
ich frage michael welche botschaft er
dem deutschen publikum vermitteln will
ich möchte nicht so da der ländlich
schweizer saison also packte junge
urbane spitze wo und mit nummern shawky
und gras macht sondern eben auch
[Musik]
fifa-chef mit den nächsten lauf deinet
alles rund und sterbehilfe schon
gedanken gemacht über das war doch
eigentlich geschickt wenn man das wird
locker handhaben
hallo
das müssen wir einmal zum kookaburra ja
sie waren super aber hallo du bist das
schafft heute oder genau wir können auch
kurz noch geben hatte er gesagt
hallo wegen dem radio termin beginnt die
vorstellung eine halbe stunde später
der saal ist fast leer nur etwa 20
zuschauer sind an diesem donnerstagabend
da
der schweizer gastarbeiter ist in
deutschland noch wenig bekannt und muss
sich anders als daheim
ein stammpublikum erst noch erspielen
ich bin finde ich komme aus der schweiz
das ist schön schon so ein tolles loch
wir gleich zu beginn das ist toll dass
ich finde das super wenn ihr euren
emotionen freien lauf lässt für mich als
weitere bisschen ungewohnt waren sie
schon mal in der schweiz
nein wie sie dir ein überschaubarer
kreis weil wir haben eine relativ
relative rigides einlass regime
eingeführt also bitte lass wirklich nur
die wirklich gut aussehen und
intelligenten berlinerinnen und berliner
rein und das ist das was ich habe das
geschafft ja ich würde gerne auch das
programm heute abend gerne möglichst gut
aufpassen deshalb völlig egal wenn
vielleicht kurz nach vorne kommt sagt
wer ist wer kommt es ist okay niebel
kinder damit der marke sich wie alle
anderen schweizer organisiert zu treffen
und deshalb gibt es alleine in der
schweiz 200.000 vereine zum beispiel
hasen züchter vereine wird apple sammle
vereine oder fußballvereine wie zum
beispiel die fifa trotz spärlichen
publikum spielt michael das gesamte
knapp zweistündige programm
und was macht dich wie vor mit diesem
geld genau sie bringt es nach zürich
dort muss es nämlich nicht versteuern
weil die fifa ist ein gemeinnütziger
schweizer verein und zufrieden fühle
mich gerade so weit unten
du bist an der richtige hör ich bin zu
hoch ja also alles verstanden
ja natürlich aber was für eine frage
kann ja sein weil ich was in den ersten
abend auch immer so um dass sie nun mit
bussen zu kalibrieren und irgendwie war
es auch irgendwie was jetzt auch ein
totaler kulturschock geist gestern abend
habe ich im einzel gespielt in luzern
da war irgendwie tausend menschen da und
haben gejohlt und was die gehen ja dann
folgen mit ode und auch beiden freunde
wenn nur ein paar wenige das lustig
finden sind trotzdem ein paar hundert
und jetzt heute was ich so klein
das war echt war ich für die nächste
vorstellung beschließen sandra und
michael anpassungen
[Applaus]
ich sehe mich immer noch extrem in der
lernphase
also ich merke jedes mal wenn ihr duft
wird man auch nach umstellung auf den
stuhl und ganz egal was ist passiert mir
fällt immer wieder neue sachen auf und
gefunden hat die hand wird funktioniert
oder die eine nutzung gurken entdeckt
immer wieder den handel also ich seh
mich entweder lernphase michael genießt
fürs erste die großstadt atmosphäre und
lässt sie auf sich wirken
die inspiration passiert eigentlich
jeden tag
ich fühle mich wie ein schwamm ich suche
einfach alles um mich herum passiert
gesprächsfetzen und denn wenn ich finde
ok eigenes thema beschäftige mehr nur
wegen des sex' integrationspolitik zum
beispiel den prestigebau am pos und burg
was ich überleben und probierte segens
kondensieren
[Musik]
gerne foto nach macht mit dir wirklich
okay jetzt sind meine so zu glauben
für den deutschen markt arbeitet michael
mit regisseur ulrich heiß ich zusammen
er hilft ihm sein schweizer programm
denn geschmack und den gegebenheiten des
deutschen publikums anzupassen
mit der kunstfigur irmgard knef steht
sich selbst als komiker auf der bühne
gestern abend hat der premiere mit
seinem neuen stück super was also wir
hatten einen riesenerfolg und standing
ovations und alles ja es war richtig
toll ganz hin und weg
schön dass jetzt ist halt schon bin
dafür stehen aber hier kommen auch boden
setzt dann da und ich will von ulrich
wissen was auf michael zukommt wenn er
in deutschland den durchbruch schaffen
will
da kommt in erster linie auf ihn zu dass
er noch mehr eine eigenständige
privatheit auf der bühne haben muss dass
man ihn sofort unterscheiden kann von
von anderen auf den anderen schweizern
aber ich denke mal dass dieses
kabarettistische politische anliegen das
er hat das ist so stark dass merkt man
immer wieder das ist weitaus mehr als
nur comedy oder parodie sondern da ist
wirklich eine ganz andere ebene drin und
wenn er geht auch mehr ausbaut und noch
ein bisschen mehr mut frech zu sein dann
sehe ich da gute chancen
am nächsten abend hat michael mehr klick
eine größere gruppe hält dem kookaburra
comedy club die betriebsfeier ab der
saal füllt sich auch miteinander ich bin
michael ich komme aus der schweiz
ob ich jetzt etwas falsches gesagt schon
zu beginn sicherlich nicht gleich zu
beginn das ist wirklich eine meiner
besten auftritte heute in europa das ist
schön wenn ich bin in euren emotionen so
verein lauf lassen das ist wirklich
gerade sehr lange hier das ist wunderbar
zu sehen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das wäre doch diese nummer gewesen
dafür treiben sie mit den genau wie
heißen sie kann sie vielleicht jemand
kurz luft geben damit sie ihren normen
sagen also ist das einzige geräusch was
sie machen können also das ist toller
mann lag das muss man auch mal es können
oder bei einer probe sich genau kurz
nach der pointe liegt schon davor ja
sonst ist wie das ganze prinzip da sonst
kann ich machen was ich will oder das
ist hoch
[Applaus]
bibel kindern in der schweiz da gibt es
auch das frauenwahlrecht da das hier das
ist us kurs ist dann stolze eidgenosse
darf nämlich wählen gehen seit 1848 das
ist ja das ist nur sie sie ist eine
ebenso stolze genoss sind auch wenn sie
ihr wahlrecht erst 1971 bekam also sogar
noch später als die frauen in somalia
oder afghanistan
klingt ein bisschen bescheuert macht
aber sinn und dann in der schweiz durfte
nie die regierung über das
frauenwahlrecht bestimmen es brauchte
stets die zustimmung des volkes also der
männer
wir wissen ja bekanntlich wie sich
männer in gruppen verhalten genau
vernünftig und frauenfreundliche
zumindest 1971 bei der dritten
abstimmung damit haben wir dann auch
noch banker ist geschlagen
und was machen us und uhr sie nun seit
sie gemeinsam wählen gehen dürfen genau
sie bleiben zu hause
denn wer interessiert sich schon für
politik
auch keine gute phase bis weihnachten
habe ich großartig kürzen uns wirklich
super drauf
ich fühle mich wohl glücksgefühl ja
wirklich glücksgefühl also fragen bin
ich glücklich dass sie jetzt klar wie er
sagt mit rhythmus gefunden auf der
berliner ja normal in passeier
umgestellt und mehr kriegen wir sie
mögen es gern wenn es böse
mit welchen erwartungen seid ihr denn
hier hergekommen mit sehr niedrigen und
die haben sich stark verbessert also ich
war sehr zufrieden wirklich war sehr
lustig bei der erste dafür den schweizer
kann eigentlich die gäste werden aber
war wirklich schön hier mit einer
schweizer mundart hier in berlin sehr
belustigt hat ja was hat ihnen gefallen
seine art hat mir gefallen machen andere
unser zuhause auf der couch sitzen und
im fernsehen zu sehen
man muss sich diese firma mal vorstellen
die buchen also so wie das aussieht
buchen die hier einen ganzen tisch
bringen sich von sich aus selber ins
gespräch wenn man nachfragt kommen sie
mit dem datenschutz muss sagen
ausprobieren ob relativ wenig zu tun ja
auch das könntest du dir mal ein
beispiel nehmen
[Musik]
ein hohen da denkt
so schön sieg ein gesangsverein
[Musik]
es freut mich dass er weiter
ihr habt ja von den replay drin und
singt auch noch wenn ich weg bin
[Applaus]
[Musik]